il
à
[Musique]
cette idée nous est venue pour pour
quand même innover on est souvent sur
scène on est souvent dans le monde
entier et on a dit qu'on décline le
spectacle de pomme cannelle sur sur un
bateau et je pense que ça sera une
première et un spectacle riche en
couleurs beaucoup de couleurs beaucoup
de traditions et je pense qu est
d'autant plus que la martinique et la
guadeloupe et même d'autres personnes
ont répondu présentes sur le bateau
pouvoir les spectacles inédits de pomme
cannelle
[Musique]
payant
m
bye
[Applaudissements]
à peine
ce qui serait intéressant c'est de voir
aussi des jeunes des jeunes qui vont
partir pour ce beau voyage que cette
belle croisière
c'est dans le cadre de l'insertion ici
et aussi le côté pédagogique parce que
nous allons rencontrer des jeunes comme
muse sur le bateau est aussi sur toutes
les différentes îles